big night coming up tonight on the voice
yeah so on the show tonight we find out
which three contestants have officially
moved on to the finals last night all
five competed in the semi-finals i'm a
fan of the show so it wasn't really like
work for me because i was there and you
know i had five questions for the stars
of the voice
i'm sure you love this i think i came in
because i had baby brain i didn't know
what i was getting into and it's been
way
way more surprisingly fun what have you
learned from the rookie season they
continue to encourage if you don't
believe in you no one else will
fill in the blank for me with this one
no matter how successful i get the one
thing about me that will never change is
my height until i get really old then
i'll shrink that i'm a family man then
i'm thankful that i'm thankful for where
i'm at
tell us about your journey here what
kind of obstacles have you gone all of
these years i had been hearing no and
know and know and know and finally i
heard yes
i'm hilly okay so adam has three you
have one what does it say if you are
able to pull this win off
you talk about screwing the pooch i do
revel and making blake feel bad i mean i
mean you tell me
i'm not saying anything i like adam
levine i'm not saying a word i don't
you